49 seconds of logos well based on the
first movie that's based on the book
that's based on a family stories this
movie should come with a disclosure at
the beginning that says you shouldn't
watch it if you're epileptic no one in
this house wakes up after the first shot
except Jodie did the demons forget she
was there and subsequently forget to
make sure she lost her hearing also and
since this door is a louvered door why
was the light only emanating from the
bottom and not the entire door through
the slats what multiple shootings by a
deranged family member surely you have
and didn't you ever read in cold blood
not even the original movie would dig
low enough to make this pun
an ellipsis is only three dots please
spellcheck your movie get it it's a
scary movie
finally Deadpool and Hit Girl together
at first shush you're not kidding
scrambled eggs are the easiest fucking
things to make does being in a beautiful
bubble keep you from really having to
make your own food I'm genuinely asking
I have no idea what dude you are clearly
not well four bedrooms three baths one
site of numerous atrocities George must
have totally missed the giant moldy spot
if he saw this the price might start to
make sense also demon-possession
[Applause]
basement torture cell for early Native
Americans who can tell the difference
this clock stopped right as the entire
family got murdered because you know
demons there was a tragedy a crime a
murder but you know we've moved on the
whole town it is a distant memory now
one thing that's confusing what's the
house murder free up until the previous
owners or is everyone who's lived there
since the 1690s been a victim if so the
real estate agents in this town should
really be charged as accessories while
houses don't kill people people kill
people
George Lutz must be part of that
powerful Pro house Lobby I'm always
hearing about
this is a period movie and a notable
period song would be way more
appropriate than whatever this is say
your prayers
this house has four bedrooms the boys
can't have their own rooms I feel like
father Callaway would take issue with
this kid confusing prayers with birthday
wishes not only did the remake excise
almost all the Catholic subplot they
explicitly made it kind of blasphemous
what is this movie trying to tell me
here
the demons live in the ventilation
system Melissa George doesn't wake me up
in the middle of the night for sexual
exploits it's generally inadvisable to
throw a kid into the mix during a sex
scene even if that kids a ghost also
Jodie was shot in the head not Hank
there has to be some afterlife haunting
rule that doesn't allow you to fabricate
the way you died to freak people out
especially while having sex what's your
name Joanie youngest daughter has an
imaginary friend who is an imaginary
cliche you have plenty of other little
girls play with in town too like Jodie
says they're all me did Jodie previously
have trouble with the other little girls
in town I would really suck to be
unpopular and murdered uh Abraham
Lincoln Jodie why would Chelsea know to
draw him if it's a big secret who he is
Jodie apparently wants to drop hints for
things that will happen later in the
movie if this is some sort of 17th
century torture device that was used in
the sealed off basement torture chamber
how did Michael find it the demons are
slowly revealing things that will be
important for later but for now don't
make any sense
I found a babysitter off a boy at the
grocery store I had to find a doctor
from a flyer left on my windshield
where's Chelsea did they cut the part
out where they looked around the house
for Chelsea her do they just beeline
straight to the boathouse a kid with a
red balloon is this the criterion
collection how did she get on the boat
in the first place ah the demon did it
didn't he then Gopi
that's not your brother's problem look
if the demon isn't gonna do anything
except watch the kids struggle with the
sink I don't
the spirits at the house do this because
Georgia's keeping it too warm in there
and those chairs is this motherfucker
Pennywise the clown this is the clearest
slate water in existence are we sure
he's not in the pool obligatory Ryan
Reynolds ABS also here here here here
and here this girl got shot in the head
but now as a ghost is being strangled by
disembodied arms on the ceiling for a
jump-scare the paranormal dimension
needs to get there together also is Jody
some kind of rogue spirit that needs to
be silenced in this version of the story
otherwise this just seems like another
boring excuse for a jump-scare your
fully functional haunted house comes
complete with a Darth Vader that's what
I found in Billy's bro
the spirits frame Billy for a rather
innocuous crime amazing the exact right
letters except for that stupid K and
catch all happen to be on the fridge
right now and how many goddamn ' comma
magnets did they have anyway it is my
belief that the ghost kids in movies are
being forced to run laps by some asshole
PE teacher who died in a freak relay
race accident any self-respecting parent
with a prepubescent teen would make this
girl put on a shirt or make her go home
they don't introduce the babysitter to
the other kids go over any other rules
tell her where they're going leave an
emergency number or even explain that
things have been slightly haunted lately
I guess since the Lutz's spent all their
money on the nice house they can't
afford a nicer place like Sbarro's say
do you French she really coming on to
this kid I know this babysitter supposed
to be awful but scare seducing the
twelve-year-old boy while the other two
kids are god-knows-where delayed
reaction aside I'm guessing these kids
also heard the gunshots we heard girls
the reactions are a little much right
here in these beds I got to see the walk
through this house was completely
unfurnished I'm sure they brought their
own bits
Jodie's what's the word dad talking like
The Little Mermaid won't make this
little girl like you this is not only
the worst babysitter ever but also one
of the most forced characters ever
written into a script this is a pretty
tough game I pull my finger also I guess
it's against the rules for humans to die
in this movie
why wouldn't Jodi steal her soul or
something instead up sticking Lisa's
finger in her head this is more gross
than anything those lugar doors are
pretty flimsy a nice swift kick would
easily break through those slats
knuckles are pretty fine here but in the
next shot these knuckles have been
murdered
does the babysitter getting carted off
to the State Board mean they don't have
to pay her goddamn babysitter's an idiot
holy George is evil and correct good to
see they kept the overabundance of
firewood shopping in this movie the
fathers need a sexy task to substitute
killing their family when my dad taught
me his dad's not ready to teach him that
now George isn't going crazy as much as
he's going tikka Sh why is the mantra of
the demon to catch him first does the
demon foresee a moment in time what
George will have to most dangerous game
is family wait I must have dozed off did
the movie end and I'm now watching the
beginning of Sweeney Todd how did he get
out of that one
was that just a hallucination or did he
actually go in there there's some pretty
important info between what we last saw
in this moment that we just cut right
through person gets attacked Rob
anything in a horror movie cliche that
would be my cue to leave but we are only
halfway through the movie so it's
clearly not theirs why don't you give
dr. stone a call then you should give
him dr. Stone's number psychiatrist I
don't know if George beginning all
high-and-mighty about seeing a
psychiatrist proper mental health is
important for everyone especially if
giant arms just tried to tear you apart
while taking a bath this family throws
around so and so is going to kill me so
often they might actually be aware
they're in a horror movie so that's
actually chloë grace moretz on the top
of the house which good for her but man
what a movie for a witch to do this
potentially deadly stunt I gotta say
that's a great view the hauntings might
be worth it
impossibly did catch their mom this is
such an awkward fall she's got her hands
in the air through two quick shots then
her hands are down by her sides it's
almost like in this shot they were
simply handing Ryan Reynolds a spare
Chloe grace Moretz just in case he
needed some extra precociousness that
day the Chelsea snap out of it as soon
as she jumped now that she's not on the
roof anymore she seems normal kid scared
of heights
Cathy loves his father Calloway known
for his house exorcisms or did she just
walk up to the first Catholic Church she
could find it was a family
they've just some time ago the people
we've met that we're living in the area
when the defeos were murdered like the
real estate agent and now this priests
are acting like those murders were in a
distant past it was just a year ago
right
George's film camera surpassed snapchat
facial recognition technology 30 years
before snapchat existed by the way this
ghost demon is a total asshole for
making 3:15 in the morning something
that seems significant but really isn't
so the family got murdered at 3:15
nobody has to be a dick about it I
understand that he's under the influence
of evil spirits and everything but it
would have to be pretty strong to make
me one
sleep in that basement George kills the
family dog that's the sin also you know
what happens at the end of the original
movie James Brolin saves the dog let's
remake Casablanca and have the plane
shot down while we're at it George Lutz
is a terrible contractor yes he is
literally blessing this mess
why would across door knob even be in a
private home and why don't the demons
have a problem with it the way they do
the holy water also that's convenient
for this particular room had a cross on
the doorknob and the door locked in this
particular way to have that cross and
upside down where the evil spirits just
banking on him looking into that death
or was it just a happy accident that he
stood there so they could also knock him
on his ass just like the original the
priest is a dick and doesn't explain
anything before leaving also you hired
poor Philip Baker hall for this bolt
they gave Rod Steiger a whole character
in the original zoom in the third time
to make this nipple really dramatic also
what is this the seventh or eighth cue
for them to leave the other article
about the Pharaoh is copied and pasted
twice on the same page or he murdered
them after 23 years researching about
the particular hauntings the lead
characters are experiencing in a horror
movie cliche that pile of maggots is
actually the first reasonable
explanation for the fly attack if info
about this house was cool enough to be
in this big-ass book wouldn't there be
people in this town that would keep it
on some kind of historic registry and
say people can't live in it because of
its creepy historic past it started a
mission for angels he's haunting wow
what an uncanny transition golem makes
an appearance in a 2005 horror remake
proving that The Return of the King
never truly ends he still seems to have
his wits about him somewhat yet he keeps
walking forward even though everything
he's seen so far is jumpy and creepy ish
and he's reacting normally to it if he
was truly under the influence of these
spirits they probably wouldn't creep him
out as bad
I got the first two pages but on my
first pass through I thought the movie
wanted me to read painting the land and
I had no idea what the movie wanted me
to get out of that I had to watch it
three times before I saw suicide
line up your shots bro butchered Indians
on my leg well let's not get carried
away he tortured the Indians on their
land
[Music]
somehow Oh No a light my balance instead
of immediately suffering a bloody and
painful death
her hair jams up the motor you can't
rewind hair bad guy Telegraph's his
intentions to his family in the audience
by making the conference before killing
everybody they don't run too and
subsequently break a window
George survives this also a good thing
they never even started on the
landscaping you know who we haven't seen
in a while
pointless jump-scare convenient chimney
ladder is convenient also is this a
composite scene what the hell is the kid
on the Left doing I'm not for murder but
this guy was just swinging an axe at
your son it's a clean kill hey how about
you run the fuck away instead I really
shoot him in the leg except when I crush
your skull with a rifle which movies
tell me only knock people out for a
couple hours why they going to the boat
don't they have a car they can drive
isn't that easier and safer especially
in this weather holy if someone told me
that was gonna happen I could have just
skipped right to this part and got in
the whole fucking movie in two seconds
this kid would be excellent at
cinemasins
the only personal possessions that
seemed to matter were a bear from a dead
girl's coffin and a kiss poster so there
was really no reason so what she's dead
movie that isn't even 90 minutes has
eight minutes of credits based upon a
screenplay would it be the screenplay
this credit could technically mean based
upon multiple Murray Street cop
Rock meet bottom
[Music]
why did you tell our daughter about it
honey Janie today I quit my job and then
I told my boss to go himself and then i
blackmailed him for almost sixty
thousand dollars pass the asparagus
[Music]
watch what you do if I sang out of tune
would you stand up and walk out on me
come on through the coast we get
together have a few laughs how's the
beeping Tommy Allsup a thing oh yeah
[Music]